[Música]
hola bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días este es
su magazine 100% dedicado al continente
africano mi nombre es andrés meza muñoz
y en esta ocasión estoy en reemplazo de
mi compañera amal benotman estos son
nuestros titulares
el canciller de alemania olaf scholz
visitó áfrica en un viaje que en parte
tenía como objetivo buscar apoyo
diplomático para ucrania en medio de la
guerra con rusia varios países del
continente se ha mantenido en neutral
entre ellos sudáfrica cuyo presidente
cree que la estrategia de occidente está
causando daños colaterales
senegal sigue conmocionada por la muerte
de 11 recién nacidos tras un incendio
desatado en un hospital al occidente del
país el ministro de salud fue relevado
de sus funciones después del accidente
que pone en relieve las fallas y los
problemas de financiación en el sistema
de salud de esta nación las autoridades
investigan los hechos tenemos reportes
desde la cara
y panamá recibió a reyes y jefes
tribales de áfrica para celebrar el mes
de la etnia negra delegaciones de países
como angola república democrática del
congo y nigeria asistieron al evento que
contó con varias celebraciones y cuyo
objetivo es acercar en varios ámbitos a
las culturas africanas y sus
descendientes en américa
en medio de su intento por diversificar
sus importaciones de suministros
energéticos y dejar de depender de rus y
el canciller alemán olaf scholz llegó a
áfrica y visito senegal y níger y
finalmente sudáfrica en un viaje que
también tenía como objetivo reunir apoyo
diplomático para ucrania pero el
presidente de este país reafirmó la
posición neutral que ha asumido desde el
inicio del conflicto y dijo que el mejor
camino para una solución sería el
diálogo
[Música]
fue su primera visita a áfrica desde el
inicio de su manda
las lluvias de tres días que nos llevó
primero a senegal y luego al ingerir
sudáfrica el canciller alemán olaf
scholz abogó por reforzar la cooperación
con el continente especialmente en
materia de transición energética
estamos debatiendo sobre cómo podríamos
diversificar nuestro suministro de gas y
dejar de depender de rusia hombros o no
y eso requiere que invirtamos en
infraestructuras que nos permitan
comprar gas natural licuado como han
elegido hacerlo muchos países del mundo
scholz también insistió en su trabajo
multilateral en la democracia pero este
mensaje reiterado desde dakar hasta
pretoria no contribuyó a reducir la
brecha diplomática que ha aparecido
entre los líderes occidentales y algunos
de sus homólogos africanos desde el
inicio de la guerra en ucrania en marzo
17 países africanos entre ellos senegal
y sudáfrica se negaron a votar contra la
agresión rusa en ucrania y el presidente
de sudáfrica civil ramaphosa justificó
su posición
alegando daños colaterales
queremos que este conflicto llegue a su
fin y una de las mejores formas de
hacerlo es llamar a un cese de
hostilidades y eso puede lograrse a
través de negociaciones
las sanciones impuestas a rusia van a
tener están teniendo un impacto general
incluso aquellos países que son
espectadores o no son parte del
conflicto también sufrirán estas
sanciones
áfrica que ha visto millones de personas
empujadas a la pobreza extrema debido a
la pandemia se ha visto afectada por el
aumento de los costos de los alimentos
debido en parte a la interrupción de las
importaciones desde los países en guerra
seguimos con noticias de senegal el
presidente macky sall destituyó a su
ministro de salud después de que un
incendio provocará la muerte de 11
recién nacidos en un hospital de bagua
ne ciudad ubicada a 100 kilómetros al
norte de dakar la tragedia que provocó
una gran conmoción y consternación entre
las familias y el público es la última
de una serie de escándalos relacionados
con las graves deficiencias de las
instituciones sanitarias públicas del
país los detalles con nuestra
corresponsal sara saco
el siniestro se produjo por un
cortocircuito según las autoridades
locales y tuvo lugar en la unidad
neonatal de este hospital donde había
once bebés ninguno sobrevivió las
consecuencias del drama fueron
inmediatas aquí el presidente macky sall
regresó con urgencia de un viaje en el
extranjero el relevo de sus funciones al
ministro de la salud declaró un luto
nacional de tres días y una
investigación está abierta pero todas
estas medidas no calman el dolor y la
rabia de los senegaleses quieren saber
cómo este accidente pudo tener lugar
sólo un año después de la muerte de
cuatro bebés en un incendio en otro
hospital del norte del país en abril una
mujer lista para dar a luz murió por
negligencia en una maternidad pública y
hace sólo unas semanas un bebé fue
llevado por error en una morgue para ser
encontrado vivo unas horas después
terminó muriendo el mismo día tras la
repetición de
de sucesos la oleada de indignación es
recorrer el país los senegaleses quieren
un cambio profundo en el sistema de
salud nuevas infraestructuras por
ejemplo la formación del personal médico
este fin de semana las autoridades han
prometido otra vez un esfuerzo pero a la
mayoría ya no les creen un hombre que
encontramos frente al hospital donde el
drama ocurrió nos dijo eso es política
hubiesen debido venir aquí hace años
este hospital es terrible ya no queremos
discursos sino cambios y eso es es una
opinión que muchos comparten aquí en
senegal
pasamos ahora a gambia porque el
miércoles 25 de mayo el gobierno del
presidente a dama barrow dio salida a
las expectativas de las víctimas de los
años de la dictadura de yahyá jammeh
barro yo declaró que estaba dispuesto a
juzgar al ex autócrata y a procesar a 70
personas nombradas en un informe
elaborado en noviembre pasado por una
comisión encargada de arrojar luz sobre
los crímenes perpetrados bajo el régimen
de jam en el gobierno reconoció que
durante 22 años las ejecuciones
extrajudiciales las violaciones las
torturas desapariciones forzadas y las
numerosas violaciones a los derechos
humanos fueron el sello de la junta
dirigida por james la comisión
contabilizó que entre 240 y 250 personas
murieron a manos del estado pero la
aparición de yamaha ante la justicia
aparece una perspectiva lejana elex
autócrata que cumplió 57 años el
miércoles vive exiliado en guinea
ecuatorial y no existe ningún acuerdo de
extradición entre ambas capitales
cambiamos de tema en zimbabue los bajos
salarios y las malas condiciones de
trabajo empujan cada vez más a
enfermeras y asistentes a emigrar en
masa al extranjero donde pueden ganar
hasta 15 veces su salario medio mensual
las que se quedan pagan por su parte el
precio de este éxodo un informe de
albert normal
agotadas por años de trabajo y de
sueldos bajos en los hospitales públicos
virginia ellos de fin y muchas otras
enfermeras sueñan ahora con salir de
zimbabwe voy a ver la otra
estamos agotadas es todo lo que puedo
decir stern
también es agotador hecho en este país
de 15 millones de habitantes sin salida
al mar la economía lleva 10 años
atravesando una crisis comida
electricidad y combustible falta huevos
y como lo demás el sistema de salud se
encuentra en un punto crítico
dado su salario y a pesar de jornadas de
trabajo de 12 horas en el hospital
'virgen ya mucha mira no tiene otra
opción que multiplicar los trabajos
esporádicos
pero a sus 52 años ha decidido tomar el
examen de inglés necesario para obtener
un visado e ir al reino unido donde los
salarios son hasta 15 veces superiores a
lo que gana en zimbabwe
en este momento las enfermeras están
recibiendo sueldos muy bajos y por
ejemplo si se quiere comprar el mercado
de tarifas interbancarias se verá que
están ganando menos de 200 dólares y si
se comprueba la tarifa del mercado
ilegal es de menos de 100 dólares así
que eso es principalmente lo que les
lleva a migrar porque son las que
mantienen a sus familias salvo en el
reino unido- la pandemia de kobe 19 creó
una demanda adicional de enfermeras
especialmente desde que el 'break' se
redujo drásticamente el número de las
que vienen de europa el país flexibilizó
entonces sus normas de migración y en
hararé la capital de zimbabwe las colas
aumentan ante los edificios
administrativos que expiden visados más
del 10 por ciento de los enfermeros y
enfermeras de los hospitales públicos
emigró el año pasado dejando atrás un
sistema sanitario que se sigue
deteriorando
vamos a orar a panamá que recibió a
reyes y jefes tribales de áfrica en un
evento que se enmarca en la celebración
del mes de la etnia negra el encuentro
se denominó viaje de expiación y
reconciliación de la madre áfrica y
reunión con su diáspora es el primero de
este tipo que se realiza para acercar a
los descendientes de áfrica que viven en
ese continente y a los que se encuentran
en américa al menos 10 delegaciones
asistieron al evento entre ellas angola
todo congo república democrática del
congo etiopía nigeria sudáfrica haití y
eeuu representantes de indígenas también
se sumaron a la actividad y durante las
jornadas se realizaron encuentros
educativos culturales y de negocios para
homenajear la herencia africana
panamá
en américa cuando conoces panamá cuando
conoces sudamérica latinoamérica el
caribe norteamérica y otras partes del
mundo donde están las personas africanas
puedes ver cuánto aportan a esas
culturas lo que trajeron con ellos world
with them de pure in the team stop the
new men no dejaron de ser humanos
continuarán poniendo cabeza fría e
influencia en todas estas culturas
influentes o these coachers to the men y
con muchas culturas son conocidas en el
mundo por la herencia africana que tiene
esta cuando hablas de música latina
chocan a la música africanas y cuando
hablas del carnaval de brasil son
tradiciones africanas
[Música]
despedimos esta emisión de áfrica siete
días al norte del continente con las
imágenes de nuevos descubrimientos en la
vasta necrópolis de saqqara en egipto se
trata de una serie de artefactos de más
de 2.500 años de antigüedad y entre los
que se encuentran 250 sarcófagos
pintados con momias bien conservadas en
su interior así como unas 150 estatua
bronce de antiguas deidades y vasijas y
una escultura de inmotec quien según
expertos revolucionó la arquitectura del
mundo antiguo
varios de los artefactos serán
trasladados al gran museo de egipto que
espera a inaugurarse cerca de las
pirámides de giza a finales de año con
la esperanza de que ayude a reactivar la
vital industria turística del país
recuerden que si quiere repetir esta u
otra emisión de nuestro programa lo
pueden hacer a través de nuestra página
web www punto frente a 24 punto com
[Música]